bro
my baby mama been with me since before
this rap [ __ ]
and you know when i be joking on
instagram and i'll be posting like oh
she outside right right or you know tell
2d i want my no it's dumb [ __ ]
to be like oh man she got that [ __ ] for
that money like [ __ ] you know i've been
here way before this [ __ ] right right
right right hey you know what i think
and this is why i say like
this is why i say
this is why i hold it down for us fat
[ __ ]
man because when they see a fat [ __ ]
they think of
oh he stank
he don't got no [ __ ]
the two fat things
i mean them the two them the two fat
most things they stereotypes stereotypes
you get no [ __ ] and you stink
facts okay
this is the natural fact
of this [ __ ] bro
like
you should see the comments i'll be
looking at the comments like bro y'all
really think this
y'all really think this
i know she ain't giving that [ __ ]
though y'all really think this huh
okay
well i got a boy listen and then they'd
be so crazy because you go to a [ __ ]
patch this baby mama ugly than a
[ __ ]
or a [ __ ] ugly as hell like man listen
do you know i gotta i gotta bro
oh my god you yo yo ain't here to eat
this [ __ ] [ __ ] if you if she see her i
got a [ __ ] so bad [ __ ] yo ain't you
want to eat this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yo
mama you watch your mind [ __ ] and i had
her before wrapped [ __ ] and i don't pay
these hoes nothing why did i be thinking
that
baby oh that's another thing they think
i'm a fat trick i was gonna say in your
song you say you like hookers
oh my [ __ ] i like
hookers
meaning i like hoes you know why i like
hoes bro cause there's so many secrets
to a good [ __ ]